- I literally like losing.
I like going through the
process of trying to win.
I think that there should be pain,
because my ambition is so great,
of course I should have
a lot of micro-losses.
(upbeat music)
- [Offscreen] You got your perspective,
I just want to be happy, don't
you just want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
- You know you're so motivated,
full of optimism,
do you have down days?
- Everybody has down days.
And I'm so scared to answer truthfully,
which is what I always do,
it's surprising how, not really.
I basically feel that down days
are saved for the death
of people you loved.
I genuinely believe everything else
is at some level controllable.
If I was to lose money,
if a bad deal happened,
if a lot of people turned
on me or made fun of me,
for some reason those things
don't bother me as much.
The death or terminal illness
of 20 or 30 people that
matter to me the most,
that scares me.
That's when I'll have a down day.
If you come back here
and we're hanging out
in six years, I would say, yes, they,
knock on wood, somebody died, right?
Not getting the deal that I wanted...
I'm always optimistic
and positive about me.
I don't judge myself the
way I think most people do.
I don't beat myself up when I have
a bad hour, day, week, or month.
And that's what I think most people do.
- When something like really
affects you during your day,
something you've put a lot of time into,
you've invested time,
energy, and money into
and it's not going right--
- That to me is part of the
game of trying to be successful.
You can't control everything.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I've been so
right about so many things,
and everyday I'm in
meetings telling people
what's about to happen
and they don't believe me,
and I'm like, "I have 20 plus years,
of a ridiculous track record."
Like, a real one now.
And still, especially
because I talk about things
that are not obvious yet or are here,
but people think are coming.
- So, you kind of minimize it
in the grand scheme of things,
you're already thinking long term?
The bigger picture, automatically?
- That's really funny the way you said it,
it just triggered something in me...
when something bad happens
my immediate reaction,
and I mean bad,
like something that would
put somebody in a one day
to one week...
Like a real rut, I immediately go to,
"Well, I'm alive and so are
the ten people I care about."
Like, literally--
- Health is good.
- You know how old people are like,
"To health."
Like health is a...
I actually live it.
- Health is wealth.
- I actually live it.
Plus I literally like losing,
I like going through the
process of trying to win.
- You like a bit of pain.
- I do, I do like the pain.
- Like the struggle.
- Because I think it's
appropriate for my ambition.
Like, I think that there should be pain
because my ambition is so great,
of course I should have
a lot of micro-losses.
Champions lose rounds, they
sometimes even lose fights.
Mohammed Ali lost five times,
but he's an all time legend,
or six, you know?
- Yeah.
- What was great for me was
because I was an entrepreneur
I tested it from the beginning.
I was learning it five,
six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve...
So by the time I was 22 I
was a veteran in my craft.
I wasn't just starting.
Most people are in school,
and just start at 22.
I was an old player in my game at 22,
I had been selling and building
businesses my whole life.
For real.
Like, I know people know my narrative,
at least the ones who
are watching it know.
I don't think actually really know
I really did business every
minute, always my whole life.
It's what I'm passionate
about, it's what I loved.
In the summer I chose to
wash people's cars for money.
I chose.
And then looking at
Jason, who I love so much,
my decision to start a company changed
the course of his life.
Impact is fun for me.
Impact is fun.
It's why I do so much content.
Like, one little Instagram video--
- Right, it was perfect.
- Like the thought that I made something
that got into your head,
that brought value that
made you want to meet me,
that's cool, that's cool how life works.
(piano chord plays)